i first want to say congratulations on
the movie i really enjoyed this but you
both did a great job thank you man um i
want to start with the most important
question though right up front uh
celtics or golden state that's uh that's
uh
right i will talk with i will go with
boston uh i play there i know the team i
know
how good they are i know how they keep
goings and the bad moments i mean we
start the season
really bad
everybody talk bad about the team and
they keep going they trust each other
and they're going to play the finals i
mean i'm going for them
and i i love them i enjoy my time there
i enjoy the city the fans and i will go
with them i also heard you're a big fan
of dunkin donuts i'm joking but you know
have you gone to dunkin donuts yes did
you like it i like it did you get that
coffee no
did you have what what flavor donut i
got dulce de leche
a white chocolate oh geez you didn't
stop it don't get donuts you just kept
going and going yes you know if you're
from new england it's literally on every
corner yes certainly a lot of yes so
celtics are golden state first of all
chocolate frosting
not if we need to first answer yeah
uh and i used to like the munchkins sell
up and i don't know if they even have
those anymore i think they do they do
good um
i i don't know who's gonna win the
series i don't know i i know that if the
celtics do pull it off
which i think there's a good possibility
they are good their defense is insane
uh
tatum's coolest sell i know you were
taking them with tight
and i i saw you with them at the hotel
yeah man yes they're good man um
they're great but good lord the warriors
are stacked too hard hard to mess with
those warriors man they got everywhere
you throw throw the ball somebody can
shoot from 60 feet out you know it's
going to be a fun series it's going to
be good cannot wait to actually see it
yes why don't you get in the ring would
be fun though yes shoot out for boston
yeah okay let's go 100 um
this is your first time making a movie
and i'm curious what actually surprised
you about this entire process that you
like didn't expect going in oh
everything i never i didn't expect how
hard is to make a movie how many times
you do it again how many hours you don't
set i thought as a fan as a movie fan i
thought doing movies is easy and i was
like oh actors are overpaid for sure no
completely no actors are underpaid
everybody on the set are underpaid they
work with every crew right yeah the crew
the cameras the directors and all the
people behind the scenes for sure like
they're working really really hard it's
tough it's tough and when we shoot the
movie the first year with covet it was
even tougher uh
it was i don't know i don't know how
they make it to be honest yeah i don't
know he asked me if i because he had to
wear a shield you know for covet he
asked me if the first day can would you
sign my shield so i wrote an imaginary
can you might can you can you imagine
that i love you watching we're not out
of stance we don't see we know each
other now for five minutes do you think
that you're gonna ask him he asked you
would you please sign
my shield i love you so much yeah so i
did and then he couldn't see after i
stopped signing autographs for his
family his friend his neighborhood
the dunkin donuts
for him yeah you think i'm gonna sign
anything for him i i'm gonna listen i i
i respect you but i'm always gonna say
that adam is telling the truth thank you
i'm an older that's good you're a good
liar you're a good young child you can't
be in a movie because you're acting so
good ah you're ridiculous
i know you're a huge basketball fan and
i'm curious how were the pickup games
when you were not shooting because i
would imagine that's half the reason you
did this let me just tell you we played
a lot of hoop but the one thing i heard
the most the entire shoot from wancho
was how did you just do that and i'd say
gotta get down low push off
and use a little english on the
backboard spinny guy called it i'd say
you gotta go with a more of a spinny
spitting
no we got so much fun we we finished the
the shooting and we just want to hoop
and he got it home with a cord and we
just meet there and a house for the
court that was pretty cool and he was
there 24 hours like i got a workout uh
we do 12 14 hours shooting and he was
like no i'm gonna play ball now he was
like i don't you sure i'm so tired i'm
26 but he yeah yeah i know i am an old
man but this guy would have an official
real workout and then come play with us
some nights you would be like yeah after
do you really want to play man because
sometimes
but i i have so much fun playing with
them that i say okay i'm going for oh
yes have fun don't watch well actually
you guys i can't believe how many nba
players are in this movie yes
blown away who actually surprised you in
terms of like their acting ability on
set all of them all of them wacho
without a doubt went the deepest uh had
the most to do so when you watch wancho
and you're
you're an actor you just go how did he
know to do it that well how did he play
it so natural how do you bring so much
uh emotion to so many scenes he is
shocking but his his buddies all the
other guys in the in the movie all
natural smooth anthony edwards great
uh uh tobias was commissioned
smith was amazing
it's it's crazy so at ease i i really i
i
really was surprised yeah good everyone
was how about how funny bobon is in the
beginning of the movie
don't you dare do what you're doing
is that
sandy no not at all oh boy i was gonna
say give me an extra 15 seconds he got
15. the uh the joke the joke in the
movie uh when he the whole i'm 22 yeah
[ __ ] rolled
my son is 12.
are you both sneaker heads are you both
into sneaky he knows more than i do i
mean yeah i like it okay so i'm curious
in an emergency you can only grab one or
two pairs that you have
what's the pair or two that you're
grabbing i will grab the air force ones
the og all white that's what my kids
wear yeah
you can wear that for anything you can
shred pants you can go a gala with that
or if you adam you can go with that um
you can do whatever you want with these
ones did you have any did both of you
because in the movie there's a lot of
sneakers yes you gave him the nice
kobe's in there yeah
can you talk about like how you decided
what shoes you wanted to wear because
that's a big thing in basketball yes i
mean we want to you know kobe was one of
my favorite uh players i look up to him
i mean i learned a lot from him after i
won the war medal with spain uh before
we start celebrating we are the world
championship i go in with kobe and
asking for a picture asking for us uh
assign my my shoes i don't know we asked
about doing something for him and and we
just came with the idea to bring the
shoes yeah he was wearing construction
boots one minute and then all of a
sudden he's in the nick covey's
the high cobies it's like the fancy ones
with the gold and black yeah yeah yeah
you look cool in those two
i by the way i wore uh durants
you played you played a couple of you
guys
yeah yeah those are nice they fit good
uh last question for you guys i would
imagine making the film especially
through covid there was one scene or
sequence that ended up being a real pain
in the ass his workout scene i would say
that's that's the longest workout
sequence i've ever seen eight to eight
minutes are running wouldn't you say
that was i think the pa for me was the
working on construction playing
construction
for me that was the
because running on the hill uh running
in front of the car was kind of funny
like
everybody every home was crowd they do
parties on the on the on the homes so
when we when we say stop everybody was
on the street cheering for us that's
true so it was a good vibe but the plane
on construction boots it was tough he
hated that yeah on that note i need to
stop i'm just going to say a sincere
congrats on the movie you both did such
a great job thank you so much thank you
thank you so much for your time thank
you good to see
you